okay let's talk a little bit about the
latest from Robert Muller and Donald
Trump we've talked about the backstory
of robert molars team wanting to meet
with Donald Trump there was resistance
from Donald Trump's lawyer you had
lawyers I think is better said a variety
of lawyers each with a slightly
different opinion on this hypothetical
meeting publicly Trump said that he
would want to do it and he would try to
do it if the circumstances are
appropriate there was a sort of debate
around well would Muller be willing to
submit written questions to Trump or if
it's going to be in person maybe the
possibility of limiting the duration of
the meeting or at least limiting the
scope to only certain topics and what
was clear all along is that this was
going to be risky for Trump no matter
what restrictions were placed if there
was an in-person meeting right for
Donald Trump to be interviewed by robert
muller or more likely investigators
working with robert muller could be very
very dangerous
Trump possibly coming in with the idea
that he can just outsmart molar or
molars investigators usually
investigators are smarter than that
often asking questions that they already
know the answers to to see if there's
any inconsistencies or maybe apparent
attempts to try to be deceptive so we
got this list of questions now that
Robert Muller would want to ask Donald
Trump and I want to think about a couple
things as we look through the list and
the New York Times obtained this list we
don't know if it's a complete list but
we know that there's nearly 50 questions
on this list we also don't know exactly
what the source was in the sense of were
these literally the questions as stated
by Trump's investigators to Trump's
lawyers or were these notes taken by
someone at the White House up to and
including Donald Trump about the sort of
general gist of the questions and we'll
get to that Donald Trump immediately
upon the release of these questions by
the New York Times tweeting that he is
not happy with it he tweeted it's so
disgraceful that the questions
concerning the Russian witch-hunt all
capitalized letters because I guess that
now is considered a proper noun were
leaked to the media no questions on
collusion oh I see you have a made-up
phony crime collusion
that never existed and an investigation
begun with illegally leaked classified
information nice now even if you can't
parse the grammar there I think we can
all sort of generally understand that
trumps not happy about the fact that
these questions are public or at least
claiming not to be happy so let's talk
about that leaking of the questions
Trump says he's mad about it New York
Times says they got the questions from
someone outside of Donald Trump's legal
team but they haven't said more about it
what appears to have happened is that
Muller's team passed along a list of
questions to Trump's team more than
likely at the request of Trump's lawyers
saying hey we want to see some of these
questions in advance
someone at the White House leaked them
now if Trump is mad at anybody he should
be mad at his own people right because
the New York Times didn't steal these
questions but it's also possible that
the leak was orchestrated by the Trump
team not as a actual leak but a planned
leak to try to deal with Jinna my's the
questions ahead of time and I actually
want to go even further there's the case
to be made that maybe Trump did the
leaking himself Michael Zeldin is a CNN
legal analyst who used to work for
robert muller and he says that the way
the questions are written including very
very poor grammar suggests that it would
maybe have been Trump himself who took
these notes and leaked the questions I
don't have a hard time believing that in
principle I just have a hard time
imagining Trump actually taking notes
during a meeting like we know he doesn't
read anything and my guess is he also
writes very very little and I just don't
see Trump being the guy taking the notes
during the meeting will we ever know who
leaked these maybe not let's get to the
questions the questions are wide-ranging
some of them are very very specific at
the same time question what did you know
about phone calls that Michael Flynn
made with Russian ambassador Sergey kis
lyac in December of 2016
publicly we've been told Trump didn't
know about that so that would be a very
interesting question for Robert Muller
to ask Trump how was the decision made
to fire Michael Flynn On February 13
2017 relates to obstruction after the
resignations what efforts were made to
reach out to Michael Flynn about seeking
immunity
or possible pardon also relates to
possible obstruction of justice
what was the purpose of your February
14th 2017 meeting with James Comey and
what was said that's an example of a
question that is open-ended but specific
right you're not asking a yes-or-no
question you're saying what was the
purpose and what was discussed and
leaving it to Donald Trump to sort of
fill in the blanks as he sees fit but
you're being very specific about which
meeting you're talking about you're not
talking about the earlier meeting with
Comey you're not talking about the phone
call with Comey you're talking about the
February 14th Valentine's Day 2017
meeting with James Comey another example
question regarding the decision to fire
mr. Comey when was it made why and who
played a role very important question in
this entire thing what did you mean when
you told Russian diplomats on May 10th
2017 that firing mr. Comey had taken the
pressure off that's the type of question
that if Trump's lawyers don't control
Trump or they get an agreement to answer
it in writing that can lead to one of
trumps words salads that could be very
very damaging by what it sort of
inadvertently exposes so this is why
it's such a risk to put Trump in the
same room what was the purpose of your
May 12th 2017 tweet this was the tweet
where Donald Trump said James Comey
better hope that there are no tapes of
our conversations very interesting topic
in this as well when did you become
aware of the Trump Tower meeting that is
a major major story particularly now
that we've heard from the Russian lawyer
Natalia vessel at skya we discussed
yesterday that she was actually working
as a Russian informant when is it that
Donald Trump learned about that and then
also they get to what did Trump know
about the communication between Roger
stone his associates Julian Assange or
WikiLeaks an increasingly interesting
topic as well which I asked Roger stone
about by the way when when we
interviewed him on the program I won't
read the full list we're linking to it
on YouTube but the big picture the most
important elements are as I said
open-ended questions but focused on
specific conversations and events and
knowledge the other element that I think
is very interesting here is that the
questions we've seen
have a very wide set of paths right they
relate to Trump conversations with
specific Russians they include Oleg arcs
that we've discussed
they include Trump's thoughts on recusal
and possible firings and hacking and
WikiLeaks and everything in between what
would be really great is if in a fit
tomorrow morning
Trump decides to call up Fox and Friends
and starts answering some of these
questions looking to sort of slam
Moeller
but maybe boneheaded Lee revealing even
more interesting answers because that's
actually been the theme of this entire
Trump Russia thing which is
self-inflicted damage had Trump never
tweeted and talked about what did or
didn't go on with Russia we would not
have anything close to the investigation
that we currently have and the the final
question that I have is is this gonna
happen right will Muller or an associate
question Trump in person there are
reports that there might be or could be
a subpoena submitted there are also
reports simultaneously that Muller might
decide to move forward without talking
to Trump altogether we don't yet know
but hopefully we will soon I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show we'll take
a quick break and be back after this
support for today's show comes from ever
quote America's largest online
marketplace for auto insurance only 5%
of drivers pay under $50 a month for
auto insurance nationally but ever quote
is helping to change that with a
proprietary matching algorithm that
helps you find the right coverage at the
right price and in fact data shows that
users who find their auto insurance
through ever quote save an average of
five hundred and thirty six dollars per
year
no wonder over three hundred thousand
shoppers use ever quotes insurance
matching services every day take
advantage of ever quotes cutting-edge
data and analytics and go to every quote
dot-com slash Pakman to compare coverage
options today